he made me shoot him kept saying I
wasn't real it was almost as if you read
different persons you're right he
sometimes can become into firmers your
wake what am I doing there
you don't remember dark army turned on
us I think I'm next stage to has never
called off 9f society still plenty of
work to do I can stop this no no you
pull the ripcord now they will have one
world catastrophes like this they occur
because men like aloud
something is happening it could be big
this is going to mark the end of a Corp
this is your moment you cannot turn away
now if you pull the right strings a
puppet will dance any way you desire the
dark army needs to know what he's done
you understand the consequences she's a
terrorist
if we don't do anything they'll be no
coming back from this
hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
mr. robot trailer one breakdown I'm
gonna do a frame by frame and then we'll
talk about the bigger things that we
learn from this mr. robot season 3
starts on October 11th so we got stuff
coming up and we should be getting more
and more of this stuff to get hyped up
as we go first thing we see in the
trailer is a quick shot of a screen I
don't know what this is personally but I
did look into it and some people said
it's a brute force password breaker
that's running in the background with
some other stuff going on we see the new
character herbing who's played by Bobby
Cannavale and he's waiting for an
elevator I guess it's the place where
stage twos going down that place where
we saw Tyrell shoot Elliott and
everything else we see the elevator
opening and it looks like Angela and one
other person's getting out this could be
urban as well but I'm not sure we see
Tyrell on the ground and we hear in the
voiceover you know he's talking about
Elliott making him shoot him so this may
be a flashback to that time some people
pointed out that he's looking up like he
might be looking at someone and there
were only those two there so that's a
mystery as far as I know we see them
cleaning up evidence the blood was where
Elliot was shot most likely we see the
mop and then we hear Tyrell explaining
what happened to Angela and like I said
he says he kept saying I wasn't real and
you know explains that we see a quick
cut of mr. robot handing the gun from
the popcorn machine to someone I would
guess it would be Tyrell and this is
probably a flashback to the 5/9 because
they haven't been in there for the fact
that the FBI's been there at this point
we see a shot of Angela looking on while
she's explaining that sometimes Elliot
can become a different person into
Tyrell we get a shot of the F Society
symbol that we've seen in the videos
picture of Edward
or mr. robot in the hospital and this is
probably back when he was alive this is
probably not as mr. robot and Elliot
said we kept seeing these shots of
Elliot's eye in there they were closed
then we see it open up this is probably
the first time he wakes up after being
shot at the end of season 2
Angela's already arrived and that's you
know the first person that he sees and
we heard her tell Tyrell that on the
phone we see a shot about it looking
confused here he could still be in the
stage to place the warehouse there and
it's either the light from a screen or a
terminal or a flashlight there's really
no way I can't look at it for a while I
couldn't figure it out see Darlene on
Elliot's couch and then we see her in a
bathroom that looks like at a public
place let me see
Irving back at the arcade with two of
the dark army guys wearing the dark army
masks I think the general consensus on
this is this must be back before we're
on five nine since there's been this FBI
stuff is going on in real time so this
hints had some flashbacks at the time
when well it hits had some flashbacks of
the three days that Elliot can't
remember when mr. robot took over and
Tyrell we see some later ones a Tyrell
so it looks like we're gonna find out
probably what happened in that period of
time and that Irving is part of it we
get another one of Darlene she's sort of
peeking around a corner and then we see
a picture of Elliott's family falling
from a shelf although I'm not sure where
that is it doesn't look like the same
place that Elliot had it at his place so
this is probably somewhere unrelated
then we see Elliot and Darlene and this
could be a lot of different things but
most likely based on the other stuff we
see they're doing something to help stop
the dark army in stage 2 we see a shot
of the arcade after the raid we see that
there's a flier there
and the police line so this is after the
FBI had come in and cleaned it up this
is a shot of mr. robot but I can't
figure out where he is it looks like
he's outside but there's not much else
there as far as what might be important
with this one there's lines around the
bank around the ATM machines we get
another shot of Darlene walking through
the streets that we saw in the teaser
see there's a tent city there for the
most part and people look like they're
not really doing so well since the 5/9
hack someone wearing an EPS aasaiya tea
mask it looks like a male and some
people have pointed out that they
thought that was Elliot's ear but I
can't tell we see Tyrell in a hiding
place that he must have been at during
the prep work for stage two and the
voice over we hear mr. robot talking
about being the architect and we have
this shot where mr. robot and Tyrell are
there but somebody else is there and it
could be Elliot I would imagine he's
talking about being the architect so
he's talking to Elliot after that
Elliot is putting on his hoodie see the
zipper and then we see him put the hood
up we see them at the hacking convention
Def Con I think people have been
referring to it as that we saw in the
other trailer there's a Coney Island
shot of the ferris wheel ride and I'm
assuming that that is the original time
and this is just a flashback here but I
could be wrong
Tyrell in his own apartment looking
upset slamming his hand on the counter
no she's not really sure if this is now
or in the past probably in the past
since I don't think he can go back home
but we saw that with price earlier and
the other teaser too so who knows we see
this shot of Elliot from behind in front
of the E Court building there's no real
reason to believe that it's not him but
a lot of people have pointed out that we
can't see who it is so it could be
someone impersonating him getting ready
to move stage 2 along there's a shot of
Minister Jang and his assistant that
we've seen a random shot of Leon just
smoking
and no idea where he's at if he's still
out west if he's in New York
Elliot walking through the streets no
clear hints here about what's going on
dark army guys sitting on a couch and I
don't know where this is there is a ball
of pills that come with Elliot's name on
it and it says sertraline which is a
common antidepressant goes by the brand
name zoloft in the US according to the
wiki it's supposed to be good for
compulsive obsessive compulsive panic
disorder and social anxiety there's
still trash burning going on it seems
that people we saw signs you know sent
you know so burn the trash for five
dollars or whatever we have someone with
a snow globe and this could be Dom's new
partner Santiago but it's fuzzy it's
funny the first time I watched it I
thought maybe Obama was making a cameo
because they show him in the TV shots we
see the Army on the subway and Elliot in
Darlene sitting there being quiet as
they go by Phillip rice finally comes
into the mix we hear what he says and
this is tied to the time that we saw on
the teaser with Tyrell and I don't know
where it fits in the timeline because of
what I just said a second ago it could
be a flashback but it's not something
that we've seen so it's just confusing
really but we'll find out I'm sure we
see Dom talking and again this is
probably talking with her new partner
after that we see her on the floor of
the FBI looking at the big board and
there's some changes to it people on
what reddit put them side by side
there's new X's over Joanna Mobley and
Trenton not really sure what they mean
there's a shot of Angelo's apartment and
it looks like things have been flipped
here remember the last time Darlene was
there she was asking for help if you
look at it this time it looks like
angela is laying out what Darlene needs
to do there's another guy wearing a mask
here with no shirt and it doesn't seem
to be any of our main characters as far
as I can tell a strange little scene
where Elliott is wearing the
jacket the mr. robot jacket he looks
confused as to why he's there or why he
has it on another shot of Irving talking
to someone and I mean we don't really
know I guess it could be that same place
where we have the stage to stuff cuz he
seems to be involved in that I mean it
seems likely that he was with Tyrell
during the time when Tyrell was missing
based on he could be in the present
timeline as well but it seems like a lot
of what he's gonna be doing is filling
us in the blanks of what happened when
they were setting it up right from 5-9
until whatever we are right now after
Elliott wakes up after being shot
there's another shot of Tyrells drinking
the vodka from the last teaser she
Minister Zhang again he's relaxing but
he's surrounded by some guards an odd
one well I think it's Tyrell I mean yeah
it is Tyrell I didn't know at first
because he has a shaggy beard and again
Irving's in the background this is what
kind of ties it up to him watching him
in the meantime or something like that
for the dark army another one of him
looking up not really sure what it is
obviously a really strange shot of Joana
she's miked up like she's on TV I don't
know why that would be though we saw her
get beat up by Scott Knowles and that
was gonna that was a trap like she
wanted to do something with that but I
don't understand why she'd be on TV a
shot of Darlene at the door at least
that's the way it's framed and Dom is
behind her and people have pointed out
these are not the same clothes that
Darlene had whenever she went there the
first time to be interrogated so this
seems to set something up with these two
working together we see mr. robot
writing on a mirror it looks like he has
chalk or some kind of solid marker he
writes something like they and then the
letter C the seeing of Angela running is
just confusing to me I don't really know
there's people there we don't know who
they are it looks like it's an E Court
building but it's been taken over or
it's been vandalized heavily so I
haven't read anything really
that's grabbed me as far as an
explanation of what
we've seen it before but yeah and it
looks like Elliott's probably in that
same building but where they're at
exactly is not sure obviously they show
the main ecord headquarter is quite a
few times and all of this stuff but I
don't think that would be that place but
who knows we get this shot again of the
people coming in from the dark army into
Elliot's apartment and then this one
really kind of stood out to me because
DOM and all these cops have their guns
drawn so it looks like they definitely
have someone outside of the court
building it doesn't have to be in front
of the E Court building it'd be
somewhere else but that's kind of what
it looks like to me we see mr. robot
holding Tyrell against the wall then
whiterose flips over a table and a
nice-looking apartment this shot of the
subway again where the guy who we don't
know for sure who it is pulling a gun
and then this is a pretty interesting
sequence here because Elliot looks like
he's walking into the e Court building
but then something distracts him and he
goes out front there's not a lot more to
go off of here because we don't know
where everything else is but he looks
like he was gonna go in and then
something distracts him and he turns
around then there's a couple more you
can't really tell what is happening and
the closing shot of Elliot he's watching
something you can see the other people
next to him are terrified to me it seems
like they're hinting that the building
that they were gonna blow up in stage
two is gonna come down but I'm not sure
that that's exactly what I mean you
figure these people be running if that
was happening unless they're from a
really safe distance so we have no idea
they're all watching something bad go
down so that's the whole frame by frame
I mean it seems like there's a lot of
stuff going on obviously we knew that
Elliot was gonna live he was gonna wake
back up from what we seen from this and
the other teaser it seems like he's
hell-bent on stopping stage two that
somehow that's gonna pit them against
Angela on some level because the dark
harmony if they're behind stage two and
she's teamed up with them well that
leaves Darlene who's
and nabbed by the FBI and Eliot to
figure out a way to stop it on their own
Angela of course has a power over Eliot
and that could be important and I think
that we're going to finally get some of
that on account of time that we didn't
know what happened back
that's not guaranteeing that Eliot will
know what it was but I think as viewers
we're gonna find out some of what
happened and the herbing is kind of the
thread that brings all that together for
us looks like that Eliot's back on meds
so maybe that means we'll see Christa
some more and it looks like things are
gonna be pretty awesome all the way
around like I don't really see anything
here that I find troubling I've been
following a lot of the interviews and
different things that people have said
and it seems like they're still gonna be
a big battle between mr. robot Eliot it
looks like here that mr. robot will be
playing a part in moving things along
with stage two which Eliot doesn't want
to have happen the price stuff is
interesting I don't know if it's in the
pasture and the present and it seems
that when we see white rose tip that
table that there's something going down
in that arena that isn't going to be
very good that could be related to
Elliot but it could also be related to
price and we know that BD Wong has been
bumped up to a regular character so I'm
hoping we get a lot of that kind of
stuff to figure out what the dark army
is actually all about especially now
that Angela is basically in bed with
White Rose so give this video a like if
you liked it make sure you subscribe to
my channel if you like mr. robot I'll be
doing episode recaps and everything I'll
be doing several videos a week during
the season after you subscribe make sure
you hit notification so you know what my
new videos come out you can follow me on
Twitter and my other social media
accounts and we'll interact over there
thanks for watching guys I'll talk to
you soon